[Music]
my girlfriend has
a lot of
guy friends it sounds like you're going
to be miserable i don't think i'm
miserable really i just yeah but it
makes you jealous and you wonder what's
going on and you wonder why not you and
you yeah i guess yeah that's misery
[Music]
yo yo yo
happy april 20th so glad you're here
we've got a packed lobby
we've got four people and they are
waving and one of them
come on man has a
atlanta brave championship shirt
ghost rose
ghost rose
you guys ruined my whatever hey this is
an exciting show here's why it's
exciting
um first the book is finally in the wild
it's in the stores and on the internet
it's everywhere now own your past change
of futures here
super hyped to have it out into the
world go get it where you get books for
those of you who have reached out from
all over the planet
and from new zealand and canada and the
middle east it's been extraordinary
people reaching out i'm so grateful you
can get it anywhere um so order the book
order it my mom's already bought ordered
several copies she's trying to drive the
numbers up for me thanks mom you're
you're awesome i would just send you
some because i'm that kind of son but
such it is and this is the first on
today's show
uh my first the i think the tubers call
it a reaction video right yes my first
reaction video
um
to the the the one and only show encanto
in konto if you're listing this on
podcast this may be one you want to go
watch on the tubes um it's going to be
the last segment here so you can turn on
go watch the last segment here but we're
going to dig into the fight between
abuela and mirabelle so good all right
hey let's go to our first call let's go
to avery in portland
hi how are you good how are you
i'm good i'm excited i am super excited
what's up
so what
let's talk
let's let's talk what's happening
so i recently got diagnosed with ocd
welcome to the club welcome to the gang
it's so fun
isn't it it's been a good time isn't it
though hey most people just do things
once we get to do them a bunch of times
and it doesn't make us feel any better
[Laughter]
no it makes everything worse
welcome to the gang
thank you i'm so excited to be a part of
this um
and i want help communicating in my
marriage without compulsively checking
in with my spouse oh you're a checker
inner
i am tell me about it
so i
check in
to see if i'm okay yep and then when
that doesn't help me feel any better
i check in that we're okay like
relationally
and then when that doesn't help
i check in to see if he's okay because i
can tell he's getting irritated with the
number of times i've checked in
and then i start compulsively
apologizing because i feel bad
that i'm checking in and so once you've
once you've effectively
and on a micro level
screwed up the relationship then it
starts to loop back over well you got to
check back in and then how are we right
because i'm not feeling good so i gotta
check back in with how how am i and then
how are we and then how are you and then
i'm so sorry and then how are my and
then the loop continues right
right
oh my gosh hey um it's
i don't know if you've ever talked to
yourself in a mirror before but that's
what you're doing right now i'm so happy
that you called me that's what
you are explaining my life um in a
nutshell which is fantastic all right so
back up a little bit tell me more about
um ocd tell me more about how this how
you came to figure this out because this
isn't just the only thing you've had
across your lifetime what are some other
things you struggle with
so
ever since i was little
i struggled with intrusive thoughts and
so i've been in therapy for a while and
it kind of just
kept getting diagnosed as anxiety
and
i couldn't ever i never was able to put
words to like the level of distress that
i felt yeah and it felt really difficult
to explain
like
why therapy wasn't helping because i
would go to my therapist and then she
would help me feel a little bit better
and then i would leave and i'd be like
i have to go back i didn't
tell my therapist like in the way that
she understands
okay can i can i change your life
okay yes
i'm i'm actually excited about this call
so um a quick to the nerds out there who
are listening
uh fellow nerds
there's all this academic um tomfoolery
there's academic gymnastics that go on
to say well is it an anxiety disorder or
is it is ocd a different type of
disorder
all that stuff stays in the classroom
and it's for people who have had a lot
of graduate school to sit around and eat
nachos and to go back and forth with
where those academic gymnastics hurt
peoples there's folks like avery who are
sitting in portland going i need this to
stop and i'm just doing what people say
in
the next expert in front of me to do
and it's not getting any better and then
here you find yourself here right and
that ocd diagnostic helped for a minute
didn't it it gave you a name to the
dragon and it was like okay
and then here we are again right back
where we were right avery
right okay so i'm gonna reframe the
whole thing for you okay okay you're in
truth intrusive thoughts are not the
problem
not even a little bit they're annoying
and they ruin everything and they make
the people around you exhausted with you
right
but they're not the problem they're
actually your body's way of trying to
solve this thing
so instead of
thinking about the intrusive thoughts
the checking in how do i stop that how
do i shift that how do i move that we're
going to change the conversation
completely you told me something really
powerful and here's how i know that i'm
on the right track
you would go meet with your counselor
and you'd feel better
and then as you left and then as one day
became two days became three became four
you started feeling worse and worse and
worse until you can loot back and see
that counselor right
right here's what that tells me your
issue is not cognitive it's not
information
it's not a
it's not a hack
you know what was helping you be okay
helping your body start to slow down
and not need intrusive thoughts to
protect it
was
deep connection with another person
and for a few minutes for 30 minutes or
for an hour your body went we are safe
in here
right
and my guess is over the course of your
lifetime you've had some sort of even if
you were not loving household partridge
in a pear tree you
had disconnected relationships
that your body was trying to solve at
some shape form or fashion that would
move from hey are we okay how about
about this what about this what about
this and the thoughts get scarier think
of it as as the thoughts get more
intrusive and get more scary and hop on
to different and more like whoa why is
that in my mind
think of that as your brain trying to
turn the volume up on the alarms that
say hey we're not safe and we're not
connected to people
in a way that is making my body be able
to relax
is that tracking at all with you
yes okay and
keep going go ahead
well and i guess what's interesting is
even while you're saying that i hear the
thought in my brain of like
how do i really know if i'm safe or not
my alarm bells feel like they're on 200
right all the time
right and so um
i've talked a little bit not a lot not
my full thoughts but i've talked a
little bit about pharmacology on the
show there is some pretty good evidence
that taking medicine for ocd especially
and
again let's be clear for those of you
with ocd there is this is on a spectrum
there are folks that every day of their
life wash their hands until they bleed
and there are people every day who have
to check the locks 38 times and they
spin and they're late and it's a
tragic loop
that's a much that's that is a much
deeper entrenched situation that needs
medication often needs deep
psychotherapy right so so hear me say
this i'm talking to someone who i see in
the mirror every morning who's
struggling with intrusive thoughts that
loop and loop and loop and they get
louder and louder and louder
sometimes medication helps it and here's
what it does it turns the alarms down so
that i can go sit with somebody
be honest about my boundaries with my
romantic partner
have some hard conversations or create
some real boundaries with my family
begin to make real relationships in my
community and my neighborhood
recommit to some friendships that i've
had start to build different um
like sleep and exercise things like that
they're gonna help my body right
that helps turn the alarms down it
doesn't solve the problem it just turns
the dial back does that make sense
yeah that like physical response almost
right right so think about um you've
been in a hotel where the uh you've been
in a hotel where the
um
the bathroom
like smoke detector is so finely set so
it's so tightly wound that just turning
on a hot shower and steaming up the
bathroom sets it off right that's where
your alarm is it's just so it's so
sensitive right now so going back to
when you were a little girl tell me
about home like how were the
relationships there
um
i think you've mentioned this on your
show before but my parents
experienced some like
we're experiencing stress and we didn't
talk about it
and so as a little kid i attributed a
lot of that stress as like my own fault
ah
okay
and you have this little voice in your
head that over the last 15 20 years has
gotten louder and louder saying we're
not okay we're not okay we're not okay
and you don't seem to be listening so
it's trying to do what it can to get
your attention okay right so let's think
of it this way just for the time being
let's leave the spinning thoughts alone
because they're actually the potential
solutions don't go to war with them okay
okay and i'll say it this way they're
stronger than you
that brain is
hundreds of thousands of years old your
thinking brain is just
is younger than that okay so you can't
go to war with those thoughts they're
just gonna get louder on you
the rea assurance obsessions are simply
your mind's way of dealing with the body
screaming for connection and help
so what we want to do is work on
feelings
and we want to work on
connection
so tell me about this husband of yours
i mean i'm super lucky he's amazing i
think
he's got incredible patience
and i think
i feel like i've learned what not to do
like i've learned that i shouldn't check
in
with my husband but it almost feels like
we don't know what to do i don't know
what to do instead like i want that
connection with my husband
to know if i'm okay or to
be able to know if he's okay on a like
much deeper level than just my
compulsion right so
i mean super super incredible guy
i feel like he's been super supportive
over my many years of therapy
so
um think of this as a problem that's
that you're probably not gonna talk your
way out of
okay so here's an example in my life
when i was really in deep down
the rabbit hole i was alice in
wonderland okay i remember um one of the
things i kept spinning out on that i
could not overcome was
i kept thinking all the financial system
was gonna come apart and this is back in
mid 2000's this isn't now when there's
every now it's now that that message
sells things um but this is back in the
day i just kept looking at all the
charts and i kept thinking this is all
coming down it's all coming down so i'm
coming down
and i would go meet with
like i remember meeting with a guy he's
just a lovely dude he's a cfo of a 150
million dollar company
and i walked him through
and he was so gentle and so kind but
basically he was like i don't know
you're none of what you're saying makes
sense
and i walked out in the first thought i
had in my head and he actually walked me
through it he showed me the math he
showed me the ark he showed me how the
debt covenants would roll and he showed
everything to me and i walked out of
that meeting and i thought this guy
doesn't know what's going on
that was my first thought because my
problem was not
that i was just missing that cornerstone
piece of information
so knowing there is not one thing in the
world your husband can say to you that's
going to turn that voice off
with a and put a period at the end of
that sentence i know this isn't going to
help what this is going to do is just
spin that wheel faster and so and by the
way you know this i'm just saying this
for the audience the more you shut that
down the more it will shoot out
somewhere else right
your brain will come up with another way
to try to get your attention and it will
be more caustic and louder and more
frenetic usually
and by the way
he's very patient my guess is you're
super fun to be around aren't you
i mean i don't know
yes you are people with ocd are a blast
and they're a lot and they're fun to
like be in
in orbit with until they're not right
but he won the lottery with you too okay
so here's what we're gonna do
when you feel intensely compulsive your
brain's trying to take off on you the
first thought is to drop your shoulders
and say huh what is my brain trying to
protect me from right now
we're gonna be curious and we're gonna
make peace with our bodies okay i'm not
going to war with the alarms anymore
i'm going to ask huh
and then i'm going to start writing this
down here's what you got to write down
how many times have me and my husband
touched today have we held hands today
have we done 30 second hugs today have
we gone for walks today have
do we have a journal that i write in
that he writes in that i write in we are
looking for connection that's going to
go miles deep
okay
some of this may be we haven't slept
together in two months now and it's just
because we got busy and then i got tired
and then this popped up and we got a kid
but your body starts to rattle on you
and we try to solve the rattle right so
let's find where are we disconnected and
let's start to practice ways that are
connecting for us
connecting for my wife it's this funny
game we call chit chat
yeah i think i talked about the show i
don't understand it
um
i don't know what i mean
and for the kids they want to come and
they now know that we have um what do we
call it adult talk talk time y'all
aren't welcome here and they just come
in like what are you all done with adult
talk time but they know it and then last
night i was playing baby dolls with my
with my daughter we were playing family
and she sent all the little kid dolls
away so that we could have adult talk
time so now it's a part of her life and
she's going to be able to carry that on
down in her in her legacy right
so
begin to
just fear it out in your soul with
curiosity where am i disconnected my
guess is there are some boundary issues
with your family you haven't dealt with
my guess is you accept crap from people
at work
and you're gonna have to deal with some
of those boundaries where you work why
you why you work you know what i mean
you're gonna have to walk through some
of those things and then here's the last
thing i'll tell you
one of like checking doors locked doors
is a thing for me
i don't um i just checked i just check
locks i don't i don't bother me anymore
you know what i mean i i there's a
couple of things i've just made peace
with
and so i have to make a couple of laps
around the house at night i just make a
couple hours i don't care
i check my car and then i'll leave and
i'll go back and check my i didn't
bother me i just now get to work 10
minutes uh well i don't get two minutes
early i would love to get to work 10
minutes early all the booths like no you
don't i get to i get to work on time and
then i end up being 5 to 10 minutes late
because i'm checking on my car that's
fine you see what i'm saying so i'm not
going to go to war with everything but
those ones that are hurting other
relationships that are beginning to bury
me a little bit
and will you hear me say this there's
peace on the other side i don't struggle
with it hardly at all anymore
now it's when i'm super exhausted when
me and my wife are having trouble we're
disconnected when i haven't seen my kids
in a while
when i'm being grumpy here at work and
i'm just going from media hit to media
hit to media hit to media hit to on the
road to back back here
it starts to show up a little bit and
it's just a reminder my body's telling
me hey let's reconnect let's get back in
touch with ourselves does that make
sense
yes okay so here's what i want you to do
30 days
we're going to start writing stuff down
and we're gonna make peace with the
alarms cool
okay is that cool and then you're gonna
tell your husband guess what we get to
do we're gonna practice connection and
he's gonna look at you and be like
uh you've said a lot of weird things and
i don't know what that means but i'm in
but what does that mean and you can say
it might mean more sex and he's going to
be like all right let's have this
conversation right so and we're going to
talk about what more connection looks
like it could be writing it could be
talking it could be him singing you
songs it could be long walks in the
neighborhood who knows what that is but
what is that gonna look like and then
you're gonna start making boundaries
avery my sister let me know in 30 days
how it goes
um everyone else struggling for this
the thoughts aren't the problem
they're just your body trying to say hey
we're not okay we're not okay we'll stop
going to war with our bodies let's start
stop going to war with our communities
and start saying hey what's the real
problem here we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they don't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
even live chat sessions with your
therapist you don't even have to see
anyone on a camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours today dr
john daloni show listeners get 10
percent off their first month so decide
to invest in yourself you are worth it
and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 percent off
that's betterhelp.com
all right we're back let's go to we're
back jack i finally get to say it let's
go talk to jack in michigan what's up
jack
hi john how are you doing good man
what's up
so
uh basically my girlfriend has
a lot of guy friends basically and
she tends to be very nice with them and
it often makes me
jealous and kind of bitter a little bit
and uncomfortable when i
see her sitting next to them and hanging
out with them and
i guess my question is how can i deal
with
getting jealous and how can i overcome
that
that's a good question man how long have
you all been dating
uh we've been together almost
about a year and a half
okay um
have you have you sat down and talked to
her about it
yeah we've we've talked about this
before how'd that go
it went pretty good um
i mean she's still gonna have those
friends out there
it went great except nothing changed it
was awesome
um so the conversation was good and so
here's the hard
truth i'm gonna give you okay
you can't change her and you can't
change her friendships the only thing
you can deal with here is you
you can decide
um i
i can't date somebody who spends a lot
of time with other guy friends who goes
out with him who hangs out who like is
always texting with them and always
calling them um who may have had you
know intimate relationships with them in
the past they may have dated in the past
i i can't do that
and so i am going to make the decision
since of of stating my boundaries firmly
and clearly and kindly not because
you're a jerk
and she can say great well my boundaries
are i am not going to date somebody that
tells me i can't have friends of the
opposite sex
and then the choice is yours man
to uphold your boundaries or to cave
into your boundaries it sounds like
you're going to be miserable
um
i don't i don't think i'm miserable
really i just
i think it really is a neat thing
because i really trust her and she
doesn't hang out with them
alone or anything she's it'll always be
in a group setting
yeah but it makes you jealous and you
wonder what's going on and you wonder
why not you
and you yeah i guess yeah that's misery
that's that's that's that's the
definition of misery
uh and so
sounds like she's been pretty clear with
her boundary
what i don't want you to do man is to
make a choice to be miserable over a
girlfriend
that's a
that's a heartbreaking choice but it's a
strange choice right
yeah
because you're gonna get married and
this will stay the same
and then you'll have your first kid and
this will stay the same
is that fair
yeah i get what you're saying she's
she's really great about it and she
understands it i know but it doesn't
matter because you're hurting
yeah
and i don't have one ounce of ill will
towards her she's allowed to do whatever
she wants
and she has chosen
to keep her guy friends over making her
current boyfriend
have peace let letting him have peace
that's her choice she made she's allowed
to do that she's a grown-up that's the
boundary she drew
fantastic i think trying to make
yourself be less jealous is an exercise
in futility you can become more mature
right you can you know what i mean like
uh you can be not bothered by immature
things
but trying to say hey it's a big deal to
me that you don't hang out with other
guys while we're dating
and her saying it's a big deal to me
that i have all the autonomy and freedom
i want in a dating relationship cool
then we're not going to work
no matter how nice and kind everybody is
you went quiet on me man what are you
thinking
i'm trying to think of what to think
yeah it's hard
so here's what i'd recommend you do and
i recognize there's so much
wound up in this like you love this
person
yeah yeah
you do
she probably loves you too right
yeah yeah
and she has her boundaries and you have
yours and
the beauty of that's why dating is
important right because you say hey
these things matter to me and you get to
practice those things and you get two
people
run up against them and you see if they
hold i had some obnoxious boundaries
when i first started like it's got to be
like this it's gotta be like this i was
wrong on almost all of them dude i was
an idiot and it's the ones that held
firm they held really firm
and
such that is right and every
relationships can i'm telling like
on the long end you're she's playing
with fire there
right and you know that
everybody knows that
um
and i don't have again i don't have any
ill will torture at all um it's playing
with fire and your heart is i mean the
alarms going off inside your body are
probably telling you the truth
but you can't control her and so you
have to be true to you
especially when you're dating this is
much messier much harder when people are
married
um man you've set a boundary and i'm
gonna suggest you honor that boundary so
i want you to write these things down
write down what you believe write down
your boundaries write down what your
needs are and hear me say this jack you
deserve them
even if that means telling somebody that
you love
i love you
and
there's going to be a period at the end
of our sentence
that's going to hurt for everybody right
there's no way that people don't hurt
moving forward you're going to hurt just
being in it you're going to hurt getting
out of it there's going to be hurt you
get to choose which hurt it's going to
be
and
when you're dating
i'm gonna really strongly suggest to
everybody out there
um be true to your boundaries be true to
them
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200.
trust me that's triple eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to
jennifer in jacksonville how to jaguar
what's up jennifer
hi how are you i'm good how are you
good thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for calling what's up
um so i'm calling about my husband um
in his life he's had a pretty
considerable amount of trauma and loss
that he's gone through
throughout the years
and that has caused a pretty big amount
of like anxiety and probably some
depression along with that
he is medicated for that from his
physician but
i also feel like he is using alcohol and
marijuana as like self-medication
so i'm just worried that you know he has
a family history of addiction
and i'm worried that it could spiral
down that rabbit hole um and i just
really don't want that for us and for
our family yeah so my question is um how
do i help him with this with this
particular issue when he doesn't seem to
feel like it's a problem
can i tell you the truth
yes you can't
and i hate that
right um
and i know you know that and i know
that's
not what anybody wants to hear but you
can't
um he's gonna have to
come to
the
[Music]
conclusion that he's worth being well
and that he's worth being loved and that
he's worth healing and he's worth
connecting
and
weed helps things slow down and helps us
forget and alcohol helps things slow
down and forget and it's a cheap
substitute chemical for connection
and
as somebody who loves somebody who's
self-medicating that way
it feels like he's cheating on you with
those it feels like you're sitting right
here and saying why why
what what is it about me that can't fill
that gap and you need to hear me say it
has nothing to do with you
okay
at the end of the day you can't the only
thing you can do is decide
what will me and my kids tolerate
when it comes to our safety when it
comes to presence when it comes to what
are we communicating to our kids that
this is what marriage looks like this is
what a husband and a dad looks like
that's all you can control
tell me about some conversations you've
had with him
um so
i i mean i've encouraged him to to go to
counseling and
we went to marriage counseling together
but he has never done individual
counseling
i do think that he knows that's
necessary but it seems like there's
always an excuse
as to why it's not going to happen you
know he doesn't have time or he doesn't
want to spend the money or
something along those lines but
he i guess when when i say he doesn't
think it's a problem i think that he
thinks um you know because he's a
functional adult he has a really good
job he has you know a wife and a
beautiful child and he's a really good
dad
i think that he just sees that and is
like i don't see what the big deal is
if i want to do these things in the
evening
gotcha
and what are you missing out on
like why is it a big deal he's got a
wife and a beautiful kid and a good job
like why don't you
once you back it off 30 jennifer
what are you missing
so
i guess he just like emotional
connection i feel like he just does
these things and then he's totally
disconnected we don't really
have like fruitful meaningful like
conversations in the evenings once we
put her to bed this is kind of what he
does and it's just
do this watch tv um and then on the
weekends you know with his guy buddies
he wants to go rage and have a good old
time and just forget about it and
i just think that
emotionally in our relationship that it
really impacts like our connection
i'm sorry that feels lonely didn't it
yes
how old your little one
she's two and i'm actually pregnant for
a second one congratulations
thank you and um if you're just
listening to this i my head drops um
it's so common for somebody for a baby
to be born and somebody with childhood
trauma
their body remembers that story
and their body sounds every alarm
possible and if you don't have the tools
on meaningful conversations you don't
have the tools
that help you lean into uncomfortable
relationships
then
mom and baby become this like just a
constant reminder of what a loser you
are and it just creates distance and
space and distance in space and so i'm
not going to beat him up the brave
hardest toughest strongest most raged up
thing he could do would be to go get
some
to lean into this discomfort
and most people most of the time lean
away
because it hurts it's hard scary it's
not an excuse it just isn't is
and
what i want you to do is get very very
specific
here's what that means
in 30 days i will no longer tolerate
marijuana in this house period we have a
two-year-old little girl
i will no longer tolerate alcohol in
this house
i need you here on
the weekends for dinner
or if you go out and get hammered and
whatever whatever whatever i need you to
know here's how this affects me
personally
you've got to be very very clear and all
of these things are i statements not you
statements not you can't go do this and
you
i'm saying in the house that i'm raising
a young daughter in that is ours by the
way
there will be no
uh we're not drinking on weeknights in
this home
period
we're going to have to learn to talk um
i am not going to stay in a marriage
where
we don't have communication
i'm not going to stay in a marriage
where between the hours of 6 00 p.m and
until you pass out i'm alone with a
laptop in netflix
it's that level of ownership of your
boundaries and then you have to have
what i think is the scariest thing for
somebody in your position it's an or
what statement
like or what
are you really going to leave them
or are you really going to hold this
boundary or are you going to cave and
you're going to say you know what
whatever
um the picture of this thing this this
facade i'm just going to keep it going
until it crashes
right that or what statement is
terrifying right
yes you've thought about it tell me what
you've been thinking about it
i mean
i obviously don't
like divorce is never an option for me
and i just i've never pictured that for
my life and i've never
pictured our kids being in the same
house with both parents
can i tell you where this usually leads
sure
it usually leads with somebody at work
being really nice to you
and you texting that person a little bit
more than you probably should
and then y'all right or
your husband senses the disconnection he
senses how frustrated you are at him and
how angry you are that he just keeps
smoking weed all the time
and he feels gross about who he has
become in his own marriage
that's where this thing usually implodes
and that's where somebody's got to flip
the lights on and say hey listen am i am
i on the right track
yeah okay so
somebody's got to flip the lights on and
say hey
we're on a bad trajectory here i miss
you
i miss you
and i don't have the tools to bridge
this gap you don't have the tools to
bridge this gap the only thing you can
do is go to counseling yourself have you
have you gone to individual
i have not okay i'd recommend that
okay because you're gonna need the
strength and the boundaries and the
practice and the all the all the all
that right and you're going to provide a
model for
this is how far i'm willing to go to get
well to connect with you
okay
instead of hey
you need to quit drinking so much at
home or i really don't like it when you
smoke weed
use i statements like
i miss you
i would like to connect in the evenings
without alcohol and without weed i don't
like sleeping with you and you've been
drinking the whole thing's just weird
i don't like having to come in and put a
blanket on you i want you to come sleep
in bed with us like right you see what
i'm saying i want these to be ownership
statements and i statements
is your husband hurting
or is he just kind of a
is he broad out trying to live out his
brows
no i mean i think he definitely hurts um
you know he didn't grow up with a father
figure his dad passed away and he's two
his mom was during middle school and
high school was a drug addict
and then he lost his best friend his
brother passed away of a heart condition
um so i think he's just
he's definitely dealt with a lot of that
in his little two yeah having a
two-year-old in the house is sounding
every alarm he's got
because his body remembers the story
this is when dad dies this is when mom
gets off the rails and she is hurting so
bad and gets stuck in a cycle um
yeah
can i just tell you i'm sorry
being lonely is the worst
and watching somebody you love love love
slowly go off the
slide
at the park is scary i'm sorry
thank you please know that um
it's not personal
you know what i mean he's trying to stay
alive he's not not loving you he's
trying to stay alive and until he
chooses that
he's worth being connected it's going to
be a hard season
please please please make a phone call
to talk to somebody today okay hang on
the line i'm going to send you a copy of
on your past change your future um
i want you to read it maybe you know
what i'm saying you too
ask them if you'll read it together
look at that look at that they're gonna
read it together
um
and y'all read it together and
it also we'll send you a copy of the
audiobook if if one of you all doesn't
read and that we all can do it together
and you can have something to talk about
and maybe it will give you a connecting
point that is different than hey i need
this you need to do this will give you a
third a third party right a third entity
that y'all can point at and say well the
book said this what do you think about
that and it makes that conversation a
little bit easier so i'm gonna send you
two of them hang on the line kelly will
get your info we'll get it shipped out
to you and we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
today
all right everybody we are back and
we're doing something that we've never
done on the show before
i don't know how i feel about it but
kelly and the gang and the youtubers
we're gonna do a reaction video
if one more person emails me or dm's me
about el encanto
and what i think about it and is it real
and is it work and is it what does it
say about
so here we go
we're going to do my first reaction
video on the show it's the encanto
reaction
about the mirabelle and a boyella fight
all right uh
nate douglas roll it up what is going on
it's okay everything's we're gonna save
the miracle the magic what are you
talking about look at our home look at
your sister he's just isabella wasn't
happy of course she's unhappy you ruined
her proposal no she needed me to ruin
her proposal and then we did all this
and the candle burn brighter and the
christmas that's why i'm in the vision
i'm saving the miracle you have to stop
mirabelle
the crack started with you
bruno left because of you
luis is losing her powers isabella's out
of control because of you i don't know
why you weren't giving a gift but it is
not an excuse for you to hurt this
family
[Music]
okay stop it right there
so
they're having two different
conversations here
mirabelle that's that's the young
young woman right
mirabelle is simply saying
can you see me
can you see the good
that i'm bringing to our home
and abuela is saying grandmother is
saying
you are in service to the bigger machine
here the facade is more important
than
what you your little feelings what you
think
do you see me versus
know your place here
what's one of the most common family
like they're just talking past each
other
and they're both of their hearts are
exploding in opposite directions even
though they're staring each other in the
eye all right hit play
[Music]
i will never
be good enough for you
will i
no matter how
hard i try
[Music]
no matter how hard
any of us tries
lisa will never be strong enough isa
won't be perfect enough all right hit
pause here
okay common move i was i was all team
mirabelle
but now she's triangulating people now
she's dragging other family members into
the formation of her boundaries now how
old is she in this movie
is she like twenty-one yeah
early twenties no
she's seven i don't wanna be like
suck it up seven-year-old if you're a 22
this is where like there's this this is
like the revelation right this is when
you start to realize oh my mom's always
gonna be like this my dad will never say
the words i'm proud of you my
husband or boyfriend will never
hear my needs right these are these
moments but it's then when you go and my
my girlfriend she sees it too
or
yeah and my dad and now i'm looping
everybody in to the formation of my
boundary and that's a mess when you
start to have these realizations that oh
this is going to be the way this always
you are going to be the way you always
are i'm the one who's got to change here
what i'd love people to do is to say
these are my boundaries i'm going to use
i statements here this is for me
my sister can watch this happen and then
she can choose to have her own
boundaries my brother can too this is
about me okay hit play now i'm all into
this family because you only saw the
worst in it bruno didn't care about this
father he loves this
this family we all love this family
you're the one that doesn't care
you are the one breaking our home you
miracle is dying because of you
[Laughter]
look at that
okay
so
ah this is when things were going well
and then it turns hollywood
the face so if you're listening to this
grandmother just had the face right the
right like the face of oh no you're
right
for the last 50 years i've excluded my
son i've
kept my thumb over everybody
this doesn't happen in reality
very very rare and it doesn't happen
with the music swelling and there's this
great big thing this idea like this
magic sentence i'm just gonna say the
magic sentence i was working with
somebody the other day and they said i'm
just waiting for that that one
that one thing that someone's gonna say
that's gonna cut through it and i
finally said that thing's not coming
right so we have this picture that when
we create boundaries the music's gonna
swell and we're gonna say our boundary
across the table we're gonna come to the
realization and they're gonna go
it was me
that never happens
usually it ends with i hate you get out
of my house
or fine then or i'm taking you out of
the will or then i'm gonna start seeing
somebody else right we wait for this
fantasy moment this perfect catharsis
and it doesn't happen
right
this ah
so abuela's
so yo i haven't seen i've seen it but i
fell asleep halfway through with my kids
i was tired and i now i'm gonna go back
and watch it it looks amazing but
here's what's important like it sounds
like abuela created a story she got
deeply hurt and she created a story
to move this family along and the story
in the short term created a lot of
beauty and a lot of cool things and
there's a lot of things that she could
talk about when it came to her kids a
select group of her grandkids is that
right close yeah it's everybody but
mirabelle has a gift as a gift right so
right but but it comes out of this pain
right the the other
the another gift wasn't recognized to
the son right and he got kicked out
or he left or something people didn't
like his gift he was like telling people
like what was going to happen in their
lives the gift of a prophet right yeah
so they yeah profits always get rid of
their town okay so he had this gift of
prophecy right
and abuela's heartbroken deep down she
is heartbroken and instead of
dropping her shoulders and weeping and
leaning into that grief
she created an entire system that props
herself up and the whole family up and
when you do that it inevitably crumbles
around you like i guess that's what is
that what happens here everything
crashes and and then flowers are going
to bloom at the end right is that how
that works
kind of yeah
i can just hear people going no that's
not how that goes
right i mean she's reacting out of this
trauma that she experienced when the
gift was created so everything that
she's doing now is pretty much an act of
fear of
i've lost my husband
we lost everything and this gift was
born out of this grief
so we're going to hang on to this thing
yeah so she is like desperately hanging
on to it because she doesn't want to
lose her family again and she's pouring
all of that
into like the gift she's like we've got
this gift so we can't let it go oh okay
also she's so the the thing that kept
her alive
is gonna be the thing that
crushes her entire system right
gosh that's great so
all along yes
realizing that the thing that kept us
going the thing that got me through the
hard thing
can also turn into the thing like being
able to hide when i had an abusive dad
is gonna be the thing that
that ruins my marriage down the road the
like um learning how to stand up for
myself and to protect my
little brother from getting abused is
gonna be the thing that gets me put in
jail for violence right so these things
that help protect us early on can be the
things that ultimately and that we
create identities around but they can be
the things that ultimately drag us under
water later on
and all this goes back to
the greatest gift you can give your
family and your children your kids is to
see them to love them along the way even
if that at this at the beginning they
don't look like they have gifts and for
those of you who are practicing thinking
about learning to create boundaries
there's no big music at the end there's
usually a lot of guilt and there's a lot
of exhaustion and there's tears
and it's right
you can create your boundaries it's good
there's no music that plays huh i wish
it did though anything someone should
just follow me around the boom box for
when i set a boundary and it goes
turns it up i make my heart feel good it
just doesn't doesn't happen all right as
we wrap up today's show hey thanks for
letting me uh for all the gang let me do
it what do you call those a reaction
video
so good here on 4 20. and as we wrap up
today's show
if you know you know
today's lyrics are from the one and only
bob marley
the song is three little birds and it
goes like this
don't worry about a thing because
everything's going to be all right
singing don't worry about a thing
because everything's going to be all
right rise up this morning smile with a
rising sun three little birds pitch by
my doorstep singing sweet songs of
melody's pure and true saying
this is my message to you ooh
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode here ye
hairy it's john with the dr john
dalone's show
just yanked us back out of the 1500s for
a minute that's where kelly likes to
live her and her romance novels some
therapists good geniuses thanks for that
are recommending a rage room or a smash
room a temper tantrum room when it comes
to kids it can be a fun and safe
activity but kids aren't allowed to use
glass or heavy duty tools like sledge
hammers only adults throwing temper
tantrums can do that here's the thing
this gets me so frustrated